(Mozart's Requiem: Lacrimosa)
- [Voiceover] I saw my Dad
cheating over Facebook.
I don't have the guts to tell
my Mom because I don't want
me and my siblings to end
up having a broken family.
- [Voiceover] I caught my Mom
cheating on my Dad, so I keyed
her car and flattened her tires.
I'm not sure how our relationship
will piece back together
after that.
- [Voiceover] I found out my
Dad was cheating on my Mom
and told her about it.
Now they're getting a divorce
and I know it's not my fault
but I feel like it is.
- [Voiceover] I found my
Mom cheating on my Dad with
one of his friends five years ago.
My Dad still doesn't know
and it kills me every day
for not telling him.
- [Voiceover] When I was
little I caught my Dad cheating
on my Mom.
I never told anyone because
I thought I could convince
myself it was just a nightmare I had.
- [Voiceover] I caught my
Dad cheating on my Mom.
He paid me $250 to keep my
mouth shut but I told her anyway
and kept the money.
- [Voiceover] I caught my Mom
cheating on my Dad and she has
no idea why I'm shutting down.
- [Voiceover] I caught my
Dad cheating with my aunt
when I was 17.
Now I'm 22 with no relationship whatsoever
and a fear of a meeting a guy like him.
I feel like I'm too broken
to love and to be loved.
- [Voicemail] I saw my Dad
cheating and he put his condom
in my room and told my
Mom it was me having sex.
I was 12.